our thoughts conditions by the languages
we speak
what of the pre-linguistic self of
childhood or the thoughts of animals and
can we distinguish between language and
the reality we describe or does language
create worlds and here to discuss this
fascinating and paradoxical question we
have a very distinguished panel so on my
right we have Hillary Lawson who was the
UK's preeminent non realist Lassa fir
and his theory closure marks a poster
Rhydian returned to metaphysics
we have Stephen Neal who's the professor
of philosophy and linguistics at City
University New York and he is a world
expert on Russell's theory of
descriptions and here we have Janna
teller who is Danish author and former
UN conflict resolution experts and Ted
of seven books include the existential
novel of nothing so to start I want to
pose the significant opening question to
our panelists let me start with Hillary
Lawson and the question is can we have
experience and thought outside of
language
most of us I suppose most of the time
imagine language as being a sort of
transparent medium we use language to
describe the world to get things that we
want and we wrote largely think of it as
being being a tool to do that say
largely transparency for a long time
philosophers treating language in much
the same way until what it's sort of
clinically described as the linguistic
term when philosophers came to think
that language was central to the way
that we think and the structure of
language therefore told us something
about the way that whether we were to
understand I thought that perhaps the
world but of course the key problem has
been in relation to language becoming
the central focus of philosophy has been
to describe what is the relationship
between language and reality language in
the world and it's going to be my
contention that this project has failed
and we've been having a good good in for
something like a hundred years and I
don't think there's any likelihood that
it's going to be successful so the
question I'd ever want to pose is why is
it further why is it groups so difficult
to describe the relationship between
language in the world and my answer to
that is because the aim of the project
was to show how language was somehow
don't referred to or described and I
don't think we can do that because I
don't think there's anything to hook
onto and that's not because of some of
my critics have argued I'm in some mad
philosopher position of saying there's
nothing out there I think there's lots
of stuff but I don't think that what's
out there comes readily divided into
bits that we might somehow refer to with
language I think that language and
indeed more generally how we experience
things is to hold the world as things
rather than to name the things that are
already out there so I think language is
a
- which enables us to hold the world as
something rather than to describe it if
we take any any object around us you
know person table you know glass
whatever it be it's a that this table we
say well what is it well you can hold it
as a table baby hold it lots of other
things you could hold it as some metal
you could hold it as a collection of
molecules you could hold it as a flat
surface I think you can hold that stuff
there in an almost infinite number of
ways and all of those different ways of
holding that bit of the world I think
are like metaphors for what to do with
it I don't think they're descriptions or
something I think what's going on is
language enables us to hold the world as
different things and those different
ways of holding the world enable us to
intervene differently and I don't think
there's any fundamental connection
between the way that we hold them and
somehow the world is ultimately because
language is just a way of holding
it's certainly true that large by the
20th century language was put at the
center of philosophy and people thought
that by dissolving problems about
language you were dissolving deep
philosophical problems with clarifying
my own every to clarify philosophical
problems at least but that changed
really in the 1980s and there's been
strong move towards thought as the
central notion rather than language and
I'm definitely part of this camp myself
and the program really initiated by Paul
Grice which took the notion of an
intention somebody having an intention
to be the center of all of that talk
about meaning so there's an issue here
about which comes first thoughts or
language and people seem to be pretty
divided on this or people like Chomsky
who think that language evolved some to
some random mutation created recursion
in the mind and we got linguistic
abilities eventually and it's not the
function of language to express thought
it's equally the function of language to
articulate your own thoughts that
sharpen your own thoughts not
necessarily communicate there are other
people I think um one of them who think
that communication with language is
parasitic upon a very rich notion of
thought already a very higher-order
types of thoughts actually needed to
even have something approximating and a
natural human language so you need what
you desire to change the mental states
of other people when you speak you
desire to make them believe other things
intend to do other things or in fact
some time to do other things that's part
of the reason that we communicate to get
reaction so the whole idea that became
very it's become I think very central
this this is this bits a little bit
controversial but the idea that thought
precedes language and this is now I
think pretty widely held but the idea
that you you produce the types of
behavior linguistic behavior or it may
be non linguistic behavior
and you intend other people to recognize
that that's precisely what you're doing
it's in virtue of you intending these
people to recognize that you intend them
to come into some state as a result of
you making these sounds or whatever that
this type of system as the content it
has so thought precedes language the
language is a great facilitator and
engraved sharpener it's certainly true
we can take actors my ex colleague John
Searle always says you can't talk about
post-industrial angst without language
that's actually true of course in for
certain types of thoughts you need
certain words with concepts associated
with them that you picked up over time
in order to get certain thoughts and you
sharpen your thoughts certainly with
language I'm sure we've all had the
experience where you've been writing
something I mean I think this actually
happens in ordinary talk could have been
a very quick very quick place but you
had the experience of writing a letter
or something and you've not quite gotta
grind to be backtracked and then change
the word because that captures more what
you're interested in but then you really
you've actually sharpened a thought
slightly as well so there's this very
important interplay between sort of
language but there's a sense of which we
have to kind of standard young kids
animals have thoughts they have so
without anything approximating a
full-blown human language
language for me definitely is only an
approximation and it's always you know a
reduction of thought but at the same
time we need that to communicate with
others what we are thinking and I see as
you like you know words and I just like
labels and as any labels it's it's a
very thin sliver of whatever we are
trying to describe with that word but
when we then put lots of these different
labels together in different forms can
be you know sentences analysis and you
know the case of fiction of course
stories they build a structure and that
structure is what actually really
communicates to the other what we're
trying to say and the stronger the
structure becomes like or you know in a
physical shape the more others can
understand what we're saying beyond what
can be comprehended with the frontal
cortex from those representation that
the words are I mean what I mean is if
you speak in a very theoretical manner
and use just you know the words as as
that representation in a theory others
will listen and understand with their
consciousness but might not feel it
because there is no structure there's a
physical structure is a theoretical
structure
[Applause]